what are some of the cues
in terms of what women want
um you know go to the gym
it's a
hotly contested debate you said
evolutionary psychology and this is uh
in the uh bro psychology forums that i
visit uh multiple times a day and no i'm
just kidding uh what what's the most
important cue of appearance
for guys um
what muscle group is the most important
to work on do women care about biceps is
what i'm asking in terms of physical
appearance um
uh
a a good um
shoulder to hip ratio
so
relatively wide shoulders relative to
hips um
is is one
women tend to prefer men who are uh
physically fit and
well
toned but not
muscle bound so like if you go to oh i
don't know someone like
those early when arnold schwarzenegger
was
doing the
mr whatever it was contest you see the
women don't find those attractive the
extremely muscle-bound guys
but they like
a guy who's physically fit
high shoulder hip ratio
uh they like guys who are physically
taller than they are
um and guys who are a bit above average
in in height so if the average so if uh
you know the average is i don't know
five nine five ten and out there for
humans depending on the culture women
prefer an inch or two taller than that
um so um so shoulders
height
dad bod
wha what's that about why don't why why
do you want a dad by what why do you
why why not
how do i define
what is a dad bod dead bod is not muscle
bound okay so out of shape a little no
no just a little bit
a little bit of uh
uh cushion for the pushing i don't know
what the kids call it these days uh but
just a little bit a little bit of fat so
what's why do they not want uh guys to
be obsessed with their body is that or
is that some evolutionary thing
yeah i think that um
women
might interpret a guy who is so obsessed
with his body that he's
they might view that as a sign of
narcissism yes
and that's not a good trait